we are now moving to the last but not
least
presentation on this track please join
me
in welcoming dr erin piazza lead
scientist for gene expression planet
development and monastery
the title of our talk is introducing
the encounter tumor signaling 360 panel
dr piazza and now turning the
presentation over
hello everyone it's a pleasure to be
here today virtually with you my name is
erin piazza i'm a senior bioinformatics
scientist at nanostring
and today it's my pleasure to introduce
you to our newest oncology panel
the tumor signaling 360 gene expression
panel
over the years at nanostring we've
generated a number of different
oncology panels trying to answer
all of the various questions we can
imagine people asking
in the field when we started this we
started with
some simple targeted questions questions
around
pan cancer pathways signaling from the
most canonical
cancer cancer signaling pathways and
then we looked at progression
those pathways that relate to uh
metastasis and the tumor micro
environment
and we also created pan cancer immune
profiling to take a deep dive
into the immune response to cancer
more recently we've created some more
targeted panels like our car t
characterization panel
looking at t cell health both pre and
post infusion for car t
products and the metabolic pathways
panel that looks deeply
at the metabolism behind cancer and the
cancer microenvironment however
we've also created some more general and
broad tools
looking at a broader array of biology to
answer questions
in oncology and those panels we call our
360
gene expression panels
the definition of a 360 panel is the 360
or comprehensive coverage
of the tumor the immune response to the
tumor and the tumor microenvironment
we've created three such panels over
time the first of which we called our
pan cancer
i o 360 panel this panel looks
again at these three areas of biology
but focuses most prominently on the
immune response to cancer
after that we also created our breast
cancer 360 panel
owing to our deep relationships in the
breast cancer space
through development of prosigna
the breast cancer 360 panel again
focuses on all of the biology
but primarily on the tumor and
specifically breast tumors
and then most recently we've created the
encounter tumor signaling 360 panel
to focus on the biology of the tumor but
do so in a way that's more generic for
all solid tumor
studies this this is the panel that i'll
be talking about
for the remainder of our our talk here
so the reason why we believe this tool
to be worthwhile to develop
is that targeted therapies continue to
be the focus for drug development
you can think about parp inhibitors braf
or mech inhibitors idh1 therapies and so
on
and we believe that it was time to
create a tool specifically
to be a companion for these sorts of
studies
and as an example of that back in 2015
when we created our pan cancer pathways
panel we started with some of the most
canonical pathways
in cancer biology this list should come
as no surprise to many of you and
includes
map kinase pi3 kinase the cell cycle
and so on things that are important and
have been known to be important in
cancer
for a great number of years however in
2018
as many of you may remember the cancer
genome atlas consortium
uh came out with a series of papers that
highlighted some of the best results
from their studies over the years and
from the cancer
genome atlas data set
one such paper focused on oncogenic
signaling pathways
in cancer and as you can see they
published a number of these
pathways and many of them were not even
included in that pain cancer pathways
panel owing to the fact that oncology as
a field continues to move
and the number of pathways and diversity
of pathways we consider for targeted
therapies
continues to develop and evolve
and so for developing this panel we
started with our best-in-class panel
development framework
process this process starts with
foundational scientific frameworks at
least where they exist
fortunately in oncology we can rely on
the
hanahan and weinberg hallmarks of cancer
which as you know is kind of a
foundational and complete framework
for thinking about questions in oncology
we can also then integrate
state-of-the-art knowledge
up to the date uh publications and other
resources
in the in the scientific literature that
help us make sure that all of the
content is up to date
and informative and then we engage our
research community resources
things like public databases high
throughput data
key opinion leaders our customers
working groups
and so on and then finally when we're
done putting together our panels we
always make sure that they integrate
well with our encounter advanced
analysis software
this software uses the pathways that we
embed into the product
to give you an understanding of pathway
regulation
and give you scores that help you
understand how the biology is moving
in your data set and then we also have a
feature called our cell type profiling
our cell type profiling is embedded in
the tumor signaling 360 panel
and many of our other panels and gives
you a relative abundance of various
immune cell types
in your your sample this is particularly
powerful especially in oncology
where such a large fraction of samples
are in ffpe
and thus cannot be subjected to cell
type sorting
or other methods of cell type abundance
scoring
so for this particular panel we started
again with the literature search
making sure we covered all hallmarks of
cancer and cancer-relevant pathways
that gave us 80 different unique sources
for genes that included databases
literature and published signatures
overall we considered over 5000 genes
and these were annotated with respect to
pathways
and then we used our internal
development software
to assess the most informative genes in
each of those pathways
within the context of tcga with
consideration in some cases for tumor
type specific pathways
in a fashion i'll explain a bit in a few
slides
and then finally we always take feedback
from our key opinion leaders to make
sure that we've
included all the content and genes that
would be relevant
for general studies so in the end we
have a comprehensive
780 gene list covering tumor signaling
the immune response and the tumor
microenvironment
and so in in owing to our goal to
incorporate biology relevant to targeted
therapies
we use the particular resource to try to
cover a number of the target genes from
fda approved and developing targeted
therapies
these include targets like stat 3
her 3 and so on just to try to make sure
again that this tool is the most
up-to-date
and relevant tool for developing novel
targeted therapeutics
some of the unique aspects of this panel
include
pathways relevant only in specific
cancer types
that includes pathways like estrogen
signaling relevant in breast ovarian and
uterine cancer
androgen signaling and prostate cancer
and then the nrf2 pathway which has
become of key importance in lung cancers
we also covered a number of different
tumor antigens that are themselves the
focus of some targeted therapies
things like prostate specific antigen
secam
gm2 which of course uh is not a gene but
it's
the enzyme that produces it can be
targeted and then new since 16.
we also have a very comprehensive
breadth of coverage
for cancer relevant pathways this
includes everything from checkpoints
to metabolism to stemness and canonical
cancer pathways
and then we also added some novel
pathways at least for us
in our oncology panels pathways like nf
kappa b
immortality and stemness and the hippo
pathway
which is a novel pathway investigated by
many people for its
uh method of integrating both cell size
cell cycle and the tumor micro
environment
and then finally we included our 18 gene
tumor inflammation signature the
signature measures a peripherally
suppressed
adaptive immune response and i'll talk a
little bit more about the development
of that signature and its role in
in the data analysis for some of our
other 360 panels
in some coming slides
we also use some unique sourcing and
annotation for this panel
it's always important especially in
cancer where
pathway components can be mutated or
deleted
or otherwise mis-expressed to measure
the components of these important
pathways themselves
however it's also important to measure
genes that are transcriptionally
regulated by these pathways
in order to measure the up or down
regulation of pathway activity itself
and so to try to get it that we included
for consideration a number of signatures
these signatures are published in the
literature a few of them are listed
below
and these signatures have been again
published
to uh to to measure pathway activity
specifically
and thus were considered for inclusion
in in the panel
we also uh used the full tcga solid
tumor data set for most
pathways but with the exception of a key
few
these included the estrogen receptor
signaling panel which
estrogen receptor signaling of course
which is only important or only
has signal in breast and uterine cancers
and then further the androgen receptor
which focus we focused on prostate
cancer as most of the signal for that
pathway as well
is only going to be seen in prostate
cancer and we wanted to make sure
that we selected the genes that were
going to be most informative
in those specific cancers where they
have relevance
and then finally we spent quite a bit of
effort to produce
slimmer annotations for maximally
informative pathway analysis
as many of you know the nature of these
pathways is such
that many pathways traffic in and
through each other
during the course of signaling
especially pathways like map kinase
and pi3 kinase that act as sort of
generic signaling components
in a number of different pathways the
problem with that is that if any of
those
genes are up or down regulated and they
touch a number of different pathways
you may get spurious or less specific
results for certain pathways of interest
and so we took efforts to again slim
line these pathways
to ensure that the genes in each were
the most
central and the most relevant to make
sure that your pathway analysis results
in the end
are going to be extremely informative
and then as always we included our cell
type profiling feature
as i mentioned before this feature
quantifies the relative abundance of
each of these 14 immune cell types
this is a method we developed a number
of years ago a colleague of mine still
the company named patrick danaher
published on this and it's been used
successfully for years
again for quantifying these immune cell
types
in the context especially of ffpe
tissues where you don't have many other
options for
for cell type quantification
so in summary our tumor signaling 360
panel
is a 780 gene expression panel
covering the tumor the micro environment
and the immune response
as always with our panels you have the
option of customizing with up to
30 additional genes of interest for you
the panel itself has 40 plus cancer
relevant pathways
including targets of fda approved and
developing therapies
it also includes our tumor inflammation
signature
and is present in both human and mouse
versions
just in case you have either human
samples or you're working on some
translational mouse studies
and so with that uh panel said we're
going to talk next
about some case studies unfortunately
this panel has only been on the market
for a few months and as such there's no
data
as of yet that we're at liberty to
discuss from this panel
but owing to the similar biology and
nature of our 360 panels
the next two stories i'll tell you are
from our pan cancer io 360
and breast cancer 360 panels that will
give you
an idea of the kind of biology and
results that you should expect to get
from the tumor signaling 360 panel
so first i'll tell you the story about
how the tumor inflammation signature was
developed
it's not just a great story to
demonstrate the power of this signature
but also to demonstrate the
possibilities
of what kinds of signatures and
information you can get out of
encounter profiling this work was done
uh by merck in combination with their
efforts around their anti-pd-1 drug
pembrolizumab they started with ffpe
tumor tissue
taken from patients uh prior to
receiving the drug
rna was just extracted and analyzed on
the encounter platform
uh depending on the custom product they
were working with they got either
anywhere from uh 400 to 600 some genes
uh of information out of their and they
used that data
to try to discover genes and signatures
associated with anti-pd1 response
so when developing their signature they
started with that initial data set
and defined and validated an initial
signature
in melanoma they continued to validate
and refine that signature
and head neck gastric cancer and then
when they had an excellent candidate for
their gene expression profile
or gep they generated the final score
based on a penalized regression model
and nine different solid tumors
and then finally that gene exploration
profile validated
versus pdl-1ic and pdf1
unselected population
the final 18 gene tumor inflammation
signature was published
paper shown here is an excellent read if
any of you are interested
the two nations i mentioned previously
quantifies a peripherally suppressed
adaptive immune response one of the
things about the signal that's unique
and helpful is that it actually contains
very much
target genes as many of you know in
developing signatures you don't always
end up measuring genes
that look related to the biology you're
trying to measure
in this case and owing to the fact that
tumor inflammation signature was
developed from targeted panels
that were already focused on the biology
of interest merck was very
quickly able to get to an informative
and biologically meaningful signature
for response to pembrolizumab the
signature is a weighted linear sum of
genes
with a and that cut off uh is able to
determine whether a tumor is immune hot
or cold and predicts likelihood of
response to pembrolizumab and many other
checkpoint therapies
in addition to the tumor inflammation
signature pain cancer i o 360 was
designed with a number of
other signatures in mind many of these
are related to the immune response as
that's the primary focus of the panel
but a few of those are also related to
the tumor itself
and to the micro environment
the tumor signaling 360 panel has that
tumor inflammation signature
and all of the immune cell type
signatures that are shown on the right
um but the but overall um
none of these other signatures have been
covered albeit the biology
is very much still covered for many of
these
biological areas
so in our first case study this was an
io360 profiling experiment
on a multi-tumor cohort from the certum
institute in paris
there was was a heavily pre-treated
population of patients
from a variety of different tumor types
the initial results are shown here
all of the items on the right hand side
of the graph
are various cell types and signatures
from the io360 panel
and you can see that these signatures
and cell types
end up clustering the samples into three
primary groups
those that are immune cold immune
intermediate
or immune hot this is sort of a common
feature
of many studies where we can very easily
segregate the tumors using this data
into these into at least two or three
categories based on immune status
when we did a gene level analysis of the
data we found
that a number of genes included in the
tumor inflammation signature
were associated with objective response
here you can see stat1 ido1 and cxcl9
again all components of the tumor
inflammation signature
are associated with the objective
response
also in a signature level analysis a
number of different signatures
including tests were associated with
objective response
first you can see tumor inflammation
signal signature itself
highlighted in the bold box but then
there were also a number of other
predictors including nk cells and th1
cells
both of those signatures included in
tumor signaling 360
and then a few key immune relevant genes
like ido1
pdl1 and pde1 all of which again
are so are included in that tumor
signaling 360 panel as well
you can also see here that overall
survival and overall response rate is
significantly associated with the tumor
inflammation signature score
again this is something very commonly
seen
in our studies with tumor inflammation
signature and multiple checkpoint
blockade studies
and then one of the other helpful
features of the i o 360 panel
is a single sample analysis that's
possible through
um a specific fee for service data
analysis that we do with that panel
in this case you can see the tumor
inflammation signature
score for this particular single sample
is high
and thus we would have predicted
response to checkpoint blockade
but unfortunately this patient did not
respond however what you can see on the
right
is a number of different signatures for
this particular sample
plotted against the population of
samples in this study
and what we can see is that even though
pd1 expression
is relatively intermediate in this
particular sample
b7h3 expression is high and maybe
the cause or the explanation for why
this particular patient
albeit having a health immune hot tumor
failed to respond to checkpoint blockade
and so now we'll switch gears and talk
next about our breast cancer 360 panel
it's important first to understand that
quite a bit of the biology
included in the breast cancer 360 panel
is
offered by this pam 50 signature the pam
50 signature
has its goal to break these samples into
four main subtypes of breast cancer
these are luminal a
luminal b her2 enriched and basal like
each of these various subtypes has
associated biology with it
both pathway biology and then biology
that's predictive
of the kind of treatment that should be
employed for each subtype
and so in this study uh the the study
was called the finx
tnbc study it is published and we were
fortunate enough to get access to the
samples from this study
it was a multi-center randomized phase 3
trial in
triple negative breast cancer which as
many of you know is one of the most
aggressive forms of breast cancer
and patients were treated with a novel
chemotherapeutic agent
called kappa cytobean there were
111 samples from this cohort some of
which
in the tx plus cex cohort
these patients were treated with uh
standard of care
chemotherapy plus kappa cytobean and
then the t
plus cef cohort these patients were
treated just with standard of care
chemotherapeutic cocktail all of these
samples were run
with the bc 360 panel and an additional
panel plus option
that included biology related to kappa
cytobeans specifically
and since cavacitabine is related to
fluorouracil
they included quite a bit of that
biology as well
so in the initial results we saw just
like we saw in the previous study
that bc360 successfully clustered the
samples
into an immune hot and immune cold
cohorts and these cohorts as you can see
in the bottom more clustered based on
various signatures or otherwise known as
mena genes
um and these signatures were um
supplemented by some of our cell type
profiling
again the same cell type profiling and
the tumor signaling 360 panel again we
see these
two key biological groups both the
immune hot
enemy and cold or depleted and enriched
and the anti-tumor immune activity
is what clusters those various samples
we also saw that the tumors in the
immune depleted subset
uh were distributed across the various
uh
tnbc subgroups so addition in addition
to pam-50
that does the initial subtyping the
panel also includes additional
triple negative breast cancer subtypes
and we see that these subtypes do not
necessarily predict
immune hot or cold tumors which is
definitely of interest because we know
that
some types of breast cancer predict
quite a bit of the biology of those
tumors
however in our results we saw that there
were a number of key immune markers
associated
with regression free survival in these
patients
first ido1 pdl1 and pdl2
all genes in the tumor signaling 360
panel
were significantly associated with
regression free survival and the
patients treated with capocitabine
and we also some some additional markers
associated with
improved regression-free survival in
these patients
and that included the endothelial cell
signature and the mast cell signature
again the mast cell signature is present
in the tumor signaling 360 panel as well
and so in summary the tumor signaling
360 panel
was designed to look at the
comprehensive biology behind the tumor
the tumor micro environment and the
immune response focusing
on tumor biology and primed for studies
investigating targeted therapeutics our
other 360 panels have already
and as you have seen shown great promise
and uncovering mechanisms of resistance
to various targeted therapies and we
look forward to the kinds of studies and
data that will be produced
on our new tumor signaling 360 panel
with that i'll thank you for your
attention and take any questions
thank you very much dr piazza for a very
informative presentation
few questions for you also
which of the 360 series
panel that um nanostring has
would be best suited for um
the study of a mythological malignancy
great question are our 360 panels
generally think
about those three areas of biology
tumor microenvironment and immune
response primarily in the context of
solid tumors where
there is a solid tumor micro environment
however in some uh some hematological
malignancies like
lymphomas there may actually be a solid
tumor micro environment
um and so in that case we we think that
the pan cancer io 360 panel
is the best panel especially because it
focuses primarily on the immune response
and the immune biology and tumor biology
in those tumors
is intricately linked however in some
hematological malignancies particularly
in leukemia
um it it would be worth taking a look at
our pan cancer immune profiling panel
that focuses pretty much solely on the
immune response
and would be an excellent choice for
looking at the comprehensive biology of
hematological malignancies especially in
cases without
a solid tumor micro environment per se
thank you can one receive a 360 data
analysis report
with the tumor signaling 360 panel
like for other of your panels
great question as well uh so for
the the 360 panels both paint cancer io
360
and breast cancer 360 have a specific
data analysis report
we did not produce one of these data
analysis reports specifically for tumor
signaling 360
and that's because we believe that the
biology of that panel was well
served by our existing pathway analysis
however in the case of people who want
to assess the tumor inflammation
signature
there is a specific analysis report that
can be generated
just for that signature and that is
something that is
is uh compatible with our tumor
signaling 360 panel
thank you how does the content
from the tumor signal in 360 panel
aligned with the content in the
cancer transcriptome atlas that is
available
through the geomets
the cancer transcriptome atlas is truly
an exciting new product
one that i'm very much looking forward
to seeing
increasing amounts of data on it
definitely covers very similar biology
uh to the tumor signaling 360 panel and
as such there is quite a bit
of overlap in the content of uh both of
those products
so um certainly if you're interested in
tumor signaling 360 panel please take a
look
at a cancer transcriptome atlas for dsp
geomics we very much look forward to uh
studies potentially on
on paired samples from both of those
soon
thank you does this panel
need a standard for the calculation of
the humor inflammation score
yes it does the tumor inflammation
signature
um does require a panel standard
that panel standard can be used also for
for batch calibration and longitudinal
studies
but certainly is required for accurate
test calculation
thank you how does the nano string
data analysis software work
our nano string data analysis software
starts in end solver
end solver is a relatively simple tool
that reads
in the proprietary data analysis formats
that come off of our instruments and
puts genes into a format that then can
be
transferred to our more advanced
analysis software
that software is written in r and has
a unique wizard tool that you can use to
select
some various options for your analysis
it imports the data from end solver and
then
with the parameters given generates
pathway scoring
cell type profiling gene set analysis
differential expression analysis and
many other
helpful figures
thank you again dr erin for the talk and
the discussion
this concludes the program for the
biomarker discovery track
thank you again to all the speakers for
their informative presentation and
discussion
as a reminder the speaker will follow up
with any question you have submitted
the i made and i want to thank you all
for
your participation